Christian Elder, Screenwriter: Tell your
story in the cut because you know that is
where the story actually lives it lives in
between the juxtaposition of two scenes,
it lives in the transition of those two scenes.
Film Courage: So it's within the cut? Christian:
Yeah that's the other thing I like to talk about
is telling the story in the cut. Telling the
story in the cut is simple, it's a little simpler
than I think a lot of people make it and people
tell writers and they tell filmmakers and they
tell directors show not tell, show not tell, show
not tell, show not tell and that can be kind of
really confusing because it's like you listen to
those words and you're like okay what does that
mean you know? What does that mean really show not
tell okay um how do you show a screenplay i don't
understand what that means you know it's like it's
like and so like when you're you're a writer and
you're like you're hitting yourself with those
words like i don't get it uh uh i'm telling
intrinsically by writing it uh you know so it can
be really confusing but see what it actually means
is tell your story in the cut because you know
that is where the story actually lives it lives
in between the juxtaposition of two scenes it it
it lives in the transition of those two scenes
so the period between those two
scenes is where all the information
of your story is uploaded so all the exposition
that you need to make in your story can be implied
it could be all implied you don't actually have to
say the exposition like like i would say like what
seventy percent of your your exposition
does not have to go into your script
it can be all in in your cut because all
you have to do is like is is set up a um
a visual cue with an action and then
cut to the end result of that action
to the aftermath and just by doing that
just by putting one picture here all right
and then putting the end result of that picture
right over here you've downloaded your or you've
uploaded your exposition done you know so like
the example i use is like is is the um is the girl
like you know at the at the bar um at the at the
hotel bar and the bartender comes up to her and
gives her a drink and then signals towards
a man at the end of the bar who waves at her
because he sends her to drink and then cut to
later they're in the in the in a hotel hallway
stumbling into her hotel suite kissing and we
know what happens you know we don't need to know
what they discussed at the bar we don't
need to know what their conversation was
we don't need to know all the details in between
we we get it we get it and it's it's a really
really simple technique and not and and there
are a lot of filmmakers um and writers that
don't avail themselves of it and there are a lot
of writers that do um number one on the list is
kenneth lonergan who is a brilliant writer and
um he knows exactly how to do that um and um
yeah william goldman also knew exactly
how to do that so but but yeah it's um
yeah it's it's a simple thing you know
more people need to do it that's all how did you
get better at telling your stories within the cut
sometimes it was hard won um because um i had
this tendency i think like a lot of new writers do
to um want to fall in love with their language
and to hold like some kind of like chunky like
diner scene with like you know some interesting
characters talking and like throwing some colorful
banter back and forth and like oh how interesting
this is and when when when i started to realize
that it was unnecessary and that not only was it
unnecessary that it was it was um it was shooting
on me myself in the foot as far as it as far as
i'm grabbing the intent the attention of readers
um it's not to say that those characters
may not have been doing or saying anything
that was um interesting or fun or anything it
was dropping the ball you know in the ball game
as far as like making making my work stand out for
others because essentially what i learned is that
in the the in the long and short of it um readers
aren't interested in um your scene they don't
care about your scene they care about the story
you're telling them that's what they care about
they don't care about your scene they
care about the story you're telling them
so if they fall in love with your story they'll
they'll they'll fall in love with your script
they're not going to fall in love with your scene
you know they're not in it to fall in love with
your scene you know so yeah although there
is something very charming about those diner
conversations i can't i know i i enjoy seeing them
you know and then you've got marge the waitress
all right what'll it be and then you know then
they she leaves and then they're trying to like
talk you know so that she doesn't well that's a
whole other i mean that's a whole other discussion
it depends on where it is and it depends on how
you do that sort of thing um um is is one thing
and you know like for example my my favorite my
one of my favorite diner conversations of course
is because it's charged you charge a scene you
charge a scene by telling it um by telling your
story in the in in cuts all right by by loading um
your story like that um heat yes excellent you you
you charge everything is very very um sparse
and very um um there's not much going on in
heat other than the the action um the reactions um
the the setups for the heist it's it's very lean
heat and then it gets to that diner scene between
patino and um and de niro and it means everything
that conversation a conversation means
everything and that's how you load those scenes
by by you know telling your story
and then you come to a scene where
there is you know more or less you know a
standoff if it's not a metaphorical standoff
it's not emotional standoff that's how
you tell stories in general you know
you can't have that standoff
in every scene of your script
otherwise you're confused about what you're
doing sure and then keeping it lighter
the 80s 90s sing-along scene which i don't know
why they used for so long where something's on
the radio somebody turns on a stereo and
now the whole group's singing together
that seems to be lost and i'm happy that that's
the case you know i don't i don't mind stuff
like that i don't i don't mind anything that's
experimental like that as long as everything
else is tight you know um you can do anything
experimental but if everything else is tight
it it it'll it will um it will like rise to the
top okay um i i i'm a i'm a personally you know
i mean it's it's not my favorite film okay but i
am a sucker for that hollow note scene in 500 days
okay all right i am a sucker for that
scene because i've been that guy okay
i've walked out of that
it's swinging like that okay so
i've been that guy so i'm a sucker
you know so i mean like so if you do
it right you know it it flies it flies.
Question For The Viewers: What
did you like about this video?